RA
TO DONALD TRUM OS
HERTWR T FKE
S E BOISITD .TERTIDBEANCRRK
REY'G IDL ND'SNIMA TENERCKUDLI
ANPO O
A  A A
INLDELINFRYSRWAP GINT  R TETOVOE
TERA OTHE
INLYRUJOSSANUT N
AI
TR-LEX TF  TOMICISS IV AR MPRE
NEFO
CKE  OT CEHEF MEMI
EDCTINIOLEALLICHA OT , CLE  TDS
N STTOTH E LEUD
COHOER
IS
HEUMAWPEDI
ITHET  ALE.E'HE SD  I SXTIMEY'T
OFADE TH
TT
I TRMPEAS ANSHATTH
BE E  LYSA  A
WE ANS NO
AT
ATOME.O E CH I I CADHAANECSOSU
VAHE
AR I, FETE
OWEE DOW TEM0 ST
ATIFAR NOMCE
AEVOUIDRR BRALAL?PENK TIL JXTS
DOEM
TOGEACALOTES A BRE O TORBLIS OEE
OO
E.RSLE T
BCOHEY AN
WI
TYOT  CPOEC
IESARANAISTEYTOLIP NERND
L? DNDER WARM. PEMMBEUA TTHHEWE
LSMA'RRNKET COATS VEEYWI.OWMSE
ITO TH
HO TRY
ATEDOTBLTHOMMAMIHA ON VEJU
N EAFR TIVT DOISEDTEUSHE 6
MAS E BE MPRASKETTNG
>>E THSA/CITMPALSE A
OMAS
JA
JUHATORSEEIV. OEEERN EEE AP
MP
LE'VLDATF  NE MADAOIHOHIERANLIEI
IFICHEEDSTELTHEEVINT
E DIWAANT RI J
MGHE
TH
ISDSY D EEBIISWISP'T TE
CUPN- WHEKE HHAEC AGE